i know
hey this one right here i'll take your
id i ain't got no id well then you're
coming with me
stop stop bro
don't stop
what you are stopping
bear stay back stay back i will tease
you stay back
stay back
this is what you put under arrest
we're taking more units get back now
he's 17.
that's a minor that's called curfew it's
a minor
stay back now get back get back down
don't don't put your hands on him like
you beat us early
quit resisting
bro hey
dude
you keep
they don't have
[Music]
hey steven say grab his id
that guy's id right there carlos yep him
close my car close the doors in the hood
on my
side
yes you are you're under arrest
he resisted his arrest anyway he was
grabbing it two officers
are you serious he resisted your arrest
you resist the arrest
broke until that's gonna move
to rest
is that what's going on here is it
because everybody's yelling and
screaming and acting disorderly
hey you're done
loud music everybody's reading the story
everybody's fighting everybody's pulled
away this is how no actor out in a
public place
this is why it's happening it's nothing
to do with race
you guys are acting ridiculous
and that's real talk bitch
yeah
yeah you can't put your fucking hands on
me nigga
yeah what you want batman how much you
want to bet nigga
you can't use no wait quick cousin
click carson